the Chinese tech giant Huawei has been
compared to a German firm that made the
gas used in Nazi death camps the
comparison was made its British MPs
grilled one of highways executives but
do you think when we come to write our
report it would be fair to compare your
company with IG Farben who manufactured
as I Colombia and soldier to the German
government during the Second World War
I think I'd paint a different picture
Kwame is in the process of building a 5g
mobile network in the UK despite
warnings from the US earlier this year
Washington blacklisted the Chinese firm
and Google suspended its business ties
with the company the u.s. banned the
company over claims that its equipment
is used by the Chinese government for
spying and has urged allies to follow
suit Jack Rasmus a professor of
political economy says the comparison
afar way - IG Farben makes no sense it's
kind of an absurd comment because you
know IG Farben x' product was designed
to kill people whereas you know Huawei's
product is designed for people to
communicate I don't know how you kill
people whether with the phone network
you can taint somebody by association
you see I mean you know you don't say
that Huawei kills people but by
associating them with a company that
whose product did do that you know you
make it sound like well you're you're
guilty by association this attack on
Huawei and all other Chinese companies
are actually here is really about this
big fight between the US and China over
who's going to dominate technology in
the next decade the trade war is
beginning to slide into an economic war
as the u.s. goes globally to try to wean
its allies away from any kind of
economic relationships with China
you